hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve coco
eating bananas but before we do i just
want to say that if you do have any
requested problems you can feel free to
leave those in the comments i do have a
large backlog
of requested problems that i'm working
through so it may take some time for me
to get there
but you can feel free to request at any
time and if you find this video helpful
don't forget to leave a like and
subscribe for more videos
so this is a pretty interesting problem
because there is a brute force solution
that we can arrive at and that brute
force solution can easily be
transitioned
into a binary search solution which is
the optimal solution for this problem so
we're going to be working our way
from the brute force to that binary
search solution so coco loves eating
bananas and we have
n piles of bananas given to us in a
piles input array
we're also given a second parameter h
which is the number of
hours that we have in order to eat all
of the bananas so we have to eat them
within h hours and so coco has a certain
eating speed where she can eat a certain
number of bananas per hour and that
variable happens to be
k and k is not an input variable that's
what we're trying to determine as the
solution for this problem
each hour she can only choose one pile
of bananas
and eat k bananas from that pile so
that's what we're trying to determine
that k
value if the pile has less than k
bananas
she'll eat all of the bananas but she's
not gonna eat any extra bananas from a
different pile so what we're saying here
is
coco can only eat at most one pile
one entire pile of bananas in a given
hour
so what does that tell us already we're
given some key information
let's say we're given a certain number
of piles right so basically the length
of p h must be greater than or equal to
the length of p
why is that because let's say we have
five piles right
so let's say we had five piles and let's
say this is what the piles look like the
values aren't too important right one
one two two
three and let's say we had h equals four
hours
well let's say k equals some really big
number like three right basically the
max of this input array okay cocoa eight
this entire pile cocaine this entire
pile this entire pile and this entire
pile
because she could only eat four piles
because we only have four hours right
coco can only eat one pile per hour so
if she ate
all four piles over here we'd still have
one left over
that's why they guarantee us that h is
always going to be greater than or equal
to the number of piles so the minimum
in this problem given this input array h
the minimum it could possibly be is
going to be five
and i sort of wrote over it but the last
important thing that they tell us in the
problem is we
want to determine that eating speed k
that cocoa is going to eat at but we
want to know the
minimum integer k the minimum eating
speed of cocoa
that she could eat all of the piles in
exactly five
hours or exactly whatever that time
interval that number of hours happens to
be
so let's take a look at this example
they give us an input array of four
piles and they give us
eight hours to eat all four of those
piles what's the minimum
k the minimum eating speed that coco
could use
to eat all of these piles in at most
eight hours so we have to eat all the
piles in eight hours
or less well the brute force would be to
start at one right because coco could
try
k equals one right can we eat all piles
in eight hours then well it will take us
three hours to eat
the first pile right three divided by
one which is our k
right three divided by one is going to
be three hours to eat this first pile
and to eat the second pile is gonna be
even more that's gonna be six hours
right six divided by one
six hours so so far we already have nine
hours and we haven't even eaten the
entire
number of piles so therefore k equals
one is not going to work
and we could just continue this brute
force approach right now try k
equals two right and then do the exact
same computation
with k equals 2. now my question to you
is what's we know that the minimum like
possible solution would be k
equals 1 right k can't be zero because
that would mean we're not eating any
pile so the minimum is one
what's the maximum that k could possibly
be
given this in parade and given this
number of hours
well remember the number of hours is
always going to be
greater than or equal to the number of
piles so in the worst case
k would basically be the max number that
happens to be in our piles for example
if k
equals 11 right that means we're able to
eat the max pile in exactly
one hour right and if we can eat the max
pile in one hour that means
every other pile is also going to take
us only
one hour so therefore we're going to eat
every single pile
in four hours and we know for sure that
this
is going to be less than whatever is
given to us as h
right we could we guaranteed that at the
beginning so really what we're doing
here
is we're going to try every single value
from 1
all the way up to 11 which happens to be
the max value of our piles
and the first value that we get that
that allows us to eat
every single pile in less than or equal
to eight hours is going to be our
output so we're gonna end up trying one
we're gonna end up trying two we're
gonna end up trying three and we're
gonna find that
four allows us to eat all the piles in
less than or equal to eight hours
so this is not a terrible solution right
even though we're brute forcing the
entire solution set
one through the max of piles it's not
gonna be terrible what's gonna be the
complexity of that well we're
potentially gonna have to iterate
through every
value in this uh potential solution set
what's that gonna be well one
through the max value of our piles right
so it's gonna be
let's say big o of the max value
of piles so max of p multiplied
by the length of p because for every k
value we're potentially gonna have to
try okay
if i e all these how many hours is that
gonna take me right so we're gonna have
to iterate through this entire array for
every
k value that we try so we're gonna get a
time complexity of max of p
multiplied by p right but that's only
we're getting this max
p from the fact that we're having to
iterate through every single value
in this k range but why should we
iterate from
one to the end of that k range why would
in which case in the worst case we'll
have to go through every single value
why don't we instead apply binary search
on this k
range what's that going to give us well
we can reduce max of p
to the log of max p so if we can improve
this this is what our time complexity is
going to be
okay so i ran out of room but this is
the improved
time complexity basically we're taking
this variable and applying a
log to it which is going to reduce it a
little bit so let me show you quickly
how that binary solution is gonna work
it's pretty straightforward and then
we're gonna jump into the code
so we're gonna be using binary search
we're given this input array and we
wanna
eat every single pile in less than or
equal to eight
hours so we know that the potential
rate that we're eating bananas at k is
gonna be between
one that's the minimum it could possibly
be the max it could possibly be is going
to be whatever the max in
our input array is we know the max value
is 11 we can find that in linear time
so then we're going to initialize a
range like this
right this entire range that we have
going all the way from 1
to that max value 11. so in other words
we're going to have a left pointer at
the minimum
and a right pointer at the maximum then
we're going to compute the middle by
taking the average of left and right
1 plus 11 divided by 2 is going to be 6
so our middle
is going to be here in other words our k
that we're trying
is going to be here this is the rate
that we're going to eat bananas at so
we're trying the rate of six
does this work can we eat all these
bananas with a rate of six bananas per
hour in less than or equal to eight
hours can we do that well
how many uh hours does the first pile
take well three bananas right
divided by the rate which is six is
gonna round up to one that means it took
us
one hour to eat the first pile the
second pile six divided by six is also
going to take
one hour so let's just count the number
of hours
so the second or the rather the third
pile seven divided by six is going to
round
up to two so that's going to take two
hours
the third pile 11 divided by six is
gonna also round up to two that means
two hours so
we just did this in six hours right is
that good does that mean we found our
solution
well six is less than or equal to eight
that means we were we were able to eat
this entire thing
in the time threshold with a rate of six
bananas per hour is this our solution
well remember
we were looking for the minimum k value
that allowed us to do this so this
might be the solution but let's try all
the smaller values or let's
let's start our binary search in this
direction to see
is there a smaller value than six that
we can use for our k value
so basically what i'm doing here is if
we're able to eat the entire pile in the
threshold what i'm gonna do
is then start searching in the left
direction so what i'm gonna do is take
my right pointer
and shift it to k minus 1 because we're
now we're searching this entire range
what if the opposite was true what if i
tried this k value but i was
only able to eat the entire banana pile
and let's say
h equals 10 hours that means i went
over the threshold right that means i
went over
the time so what does that mean does
that modify our binary search well what
that tells us is our rate of eating
bananas 6 was too small we
didn't have enough time to eat all the
bananas in the given available time
so what we have to do is increase our
rate of k
right so in that case what i would do is
i would search the right portion
of the range so what i would do is take
the left pointer and set it to k
plus one over here at the seven so
that's how this binary search is going
to be working but so far we do have one
possible solution
and that's six so now our new right
pointer is pointing over here and our
result is
for now going to be six so once again
we're going to take the left and right
add them together divide by two that's
going to give us one plus five divided
by two is three so our k
is now going to be at this three value
so now let's check
can we eat all the bananas in less than
or equal
to eight hours how many hours does the
first take us well we're eating at a
rate of three bananas per hour the first
pile
is three that's going to take us one
hour to eat it the second pile
six bananas divided by three that's
going to take two hours the third pile
seven divided by three rounding up
is going to be three hours to eat that
pile
last pile 11 divided by three rounded up
is going to be four hours so when we
total all of this
up it's going to give us i think 10
hours so just like we discussed before
we went
over our threshold we we took too long
to eat these bananas so what that tells
us is this did not work
three bananas per hour doesn't work
let's start searching to the right of
our range
and remember when we took this right
pointer and shifted it
what we basically did was we said that
none of these values are ever going to
be considered again we're now searching
in the other range that's how binary
search works remember so since this did
not
work we're not searching it and we're
not going to search any of the values to
the left of it so what we're going to do
is take this left pointer
set it to k plus 1. so once again we're
going to take our pointers add them
together divide by 2
and we'll in this case we'll just round
down so nine divided by two is going to
be four so i'm going to put my k value
basically where left happens to be at
four
so let's see with a rate of k equals
four can we eat all the bananas in less
than or equal to eight hours the first
pile takes one hour the second pile
takes two hours
the third pile takes two hours and the
last pile takes three hours
so totaling all of this up we get eight
right so we were able to eat all the
bananas
in less than or equal to eight hours if
we had a rate of
four so basically let's compare that to
our current result
so far we found a value with six so
really we can update this six and say
there's a smaller rate that we can use
that happens to be
four so now that we did find a potential
result four let's see if we can find an
even
smaller one remember that's what we did
before if we find a k that works we're
gonna try to find an even smaller one
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
set our right pointer
shifted over here but notice how now
the left and right pointers are not in
the correct order right
left should always be to the left of the
right pointer that's basically how you
know
that our binary search has stopped we
don't have to continue the binary search
anymore right and that makes sense
because now we're searching values that
we previously crossed out we crossed
these out so how can we search them
again
it makes no sense so now we can stop the
binary search
and we can return the current result
which happens to be four
four is the minimum rate of bananas that
cocoa could eat to eat all bananas
in less than or equal to eight hours
with that being said let's jump into the
code now
so just like i mentioned we are gonna
have our left and right pointers
initially
set to one left is going to be one and
right is going to be the max that
happens to
exist in our piles input array now the
result we're not going to initialize it
to 0
initially because remember we're looking
for the minimum so i'm just going to
initialize it to r
which is the max in our piles because we
know at least this will work this is the
max
that our solution could possibly be and
now we just start binary searching
while our left and right pointers are in
the correct order
we can compute the k by adding the left
and right together and dividing by two
and we want to
count for this value k for this rate k
how many hours does it take to eat all
bananas so let's initialize hours to
zero and go through every pile
in the input array piles so for any
given pile p
we can divide it by k which tells us how
many hours it took but remember we have
to round
up so there's a function in python
math.ceiling which will round
this up for us and whatever that happens
to be is what we can add to our hours
total once we've done that then at the
end
of that loop we're going to check if
hours happens to be less than or equal
to
h the given input if it is that means we
can update our result
to a new minimum right take the minimum
of the result and whatever
k happens to be k is that rate that
we're looking for
and if this is the case then how are we
going to update our binary search well
we're going to look for an even
smaller k so what we're going to do is
set our right pointer
equal to k minus 1. we're going to
search the left portion now
if this wasn't true how would we update
our binary search in the opposite case
then we would take our left pointer
and set it to k plus 1 because that
means the rate was too small so we need
to find an even bigger
rate that will allow us to eat the
bananas in the given time interval
and at the end of this loop once the
binary search has stopped we know that
we're going to be returning that result
variable which tells us what the minimum
k happens to be
and believe it or not that is the entire
result so i hope this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching